So, what I'd like to do now is talk quickly about an example of testing done right.
The example that I'm going to use is an open source database called SQLite.
And you can read about it more at the URL here.
And so what SQLite is, this small open source database which is designed to be
easily embeddable in other applications.
It's really very widely used by companies like Airbus and Dropbox.
It's used in various Apple products, Android phones run SQLite inside
and really a lot more examples.
And by the way, SQLite has good Python bindings if you want to use it yourself.
So, this database is implemented in about 78,000 lines of code.
So, you can see it's a sort of a medium to small size project as software projects go.
Now, on the other hand, the test suite for SQLite comes out to more than 91 million lines of codes.
So another way to think about that is, it's more than 1000 times more tests than code.
So, if we have SQLite's code over here, it can be dwarfed by this gigantic mountain of test code.
And so we might ask as well, what's in this test code? How is SQLite tested?
What it turns out is the author of SQLite has achieved
a 100 percent branch coverage and 100% MCDC coverage.
The author has done a large amount of random testing
and that'll be the subject of units 4, 5, and 6 of this class.
Counter value testing has been used. The code contains a ton of assertions.
It's one of the val render tool I mentioned earlier that is good
for finding bugs in programs written in C.
SQLIte is subjected to integer over flow checks and a large
amount of false injection test are performed.
So, what you can see here is that almost everything I've told you about in this course so far.
Almost every single testing technique and many of the coverage metrics have been applied to SQLite,
and the result is generally, a really solid piece of software.
One reaction you might have when you see a thousand times
more tests than code is that it's pretty extreme.
On the other hand, when you consider the large number and wide variety of users that SQLite has,
it's pretty great that it has been tested so thoroughly.
Of course, what I'm not doing here is advocating that you go out and write
a thousand times more lines of tests than you have code.
On the other hand, it's nice to see that certain people
who have extremely widely used codes actually do this kind of thing.